surgida por primera vez hace 10 años la
maratón internacional Palestina celebra
su novena edición con un récord de
participantes
14.000 mientras que 1800 extranjeros han
venido de más de 90 países en la carrera
principal de 42 kilómetros cruzaron la
meta primeros los
atletascar de Sierra Leona y también la
atleta danesa bucha eriksen todo junto a
la icónica Basílica de la Natividad
una ruta bastante dura muchas subidas y
bajadas pero en general me gustó
suelo correr en Francia pero quería
participar en una carrera simbólica
sobre la libertad la paz
y los 42 kilómetros con la
particularidad de que voy descalzo No
todo es bonito vemos muros muy triste ya
sabes que quiero decir
el lema de la maratón es por la libertad
de movimiento Pues busca denunciar como
diariamente los palestinos sufren las
restricciones por el muro de separación
israelí y también los controles de ahí
que la ruta pase junto a dos campos de
refugiados y tenga que dar dos vueltas
dentro de Belén para completar esos 42
kilómetros una distancia que de no haber
restricciones se podría correr de Belén
a ebron uniendo estas dos ciudades
palestinas
aquí en Palestina estamos luchando no se
imaginan cuánto enfrentamos dificultades
todos los días cuando nos movemos de una
ciudad a otra o si viajamos por el mundo
nosotros los palestinos estamos felices
de vivir queremos libertad queremos que
estos muros sean derribados para que
podamos ir a cualquier lugar
[Música]
con una medalla hecha de árbol de olivo
esta competencia combina lo profesional
con lo recreativo por eso ahí también
distancias de 21 kilómetros 10
kilómetros y una carrera más familiar
para todos todos hoy precisamente están
puestos su camiseta su dorsal no solo
para celebrar el deporte sino también
para celebrar una causa